i'm just trying to think like what i did
during those eight days it just seems
like oh we went to the cigarettes
concert
oh [ __ ] we did that was last week what
the [ __ ] oh what concert cigars we went
to so garten i went to uh a concert of a
band that we both really liked cigaros
songs um you might know one of them okay
what was that one song that was like
really big in like british tv that you
told me about is hoppy potler
yeah that's this is the problem with
cigarette songs all the song titles are
in icelandic so if you don't know
the name of the song you're just like
what was that one song the one that's
like this is
and they're like are you singing the
halo theme oh oh no it's like a beta
halo yeah yeah
uh happy parlor is the one that's like
uh it's like oh people yeah
they all sound like that's not what it's
like they're all
yeah [ __ ] amazing like probably one
of the best concerts i've been to in my
life yeah yeah i think it was the best
concert i i went to in my life i mean it
was there are some i think bands that
work better in a live setting and i
think sega ross is one of those bands
that
i've experienced them now live and i
can't imagine experiencing them anything
but yeah you know absolutely because
it's kind of like they have such a very
of unique style right because it's not
like it's not like your typical kind of
songs kind of like rocky songs it's very
i don't how would you describe it joey
you're the music guy i'm having trouble
finding words like i've i've always said
to say like to people that like
cigarettes music is kind of like
it's like advanced
church hymns
you know what i mean
it's like because it's like it's the
feeling of like when you listen to a
church him right you don't have to be
religious in any way but the sound and
the style of a church him is like oh
this is like i can understand why they
play this kind of music in churches
because it's like it's very
transcendental it's very like
it's like
religious you know but like it's very
like pure and like transcendental and
very like it gives you that feeling of
like oh you know this is very spiritual
yeah and cigarettes is like that but
like
the alpha version of it yeah yeah
basically
it's
i don't i don't really know how to
describe their songs i can just describe
what it means to me and it's every time
i hear a sega ross song it just like it
makes me emotional it makes me feel
things that i can't explain going to
going to the going to this concert and
hearing
[Music]
turning to joey and being like i'm i'm
still like processing what we what we
just did yeah
like i didn't even know how to do it it
was definitely like it wasn't the kind
of like shows where you're like in a
mosh pit and you're like freaking out
and then afterwards you're like damn
that was [ __ ] awesome that was so
hype hell yeah it was more like the ones
where you just like you're sitting down
quietly after every song finishes you're
clapping and then the next one kicks in
and you're just like engrossed it's like
a full body experience and like with
some of their songs like oh my god like
those like speakers that they had at in
this hall they were working overtime bro
like you could feel this
just pulsating through your body and
you're just sitting there like a 4d
movie just like yeah like just taking it
all in because you don't know what else
to do
yeah
it was crazy oh my god it was it was so
amazing i mean like could have been like
indoctrinated or something because that
was just like how absorbed i was into
this experience you know it was just one
of the most it was the most incredible
concert i've ever been to i i still i'm
processing it to this day yeah i do not
know how to describe beeps and boops it
was very nice
you know it's lightning in a bottle man
you can't explain that no it was just i
get it i get it
it's it's impossible to explain how a
gig makes you feel yeah yeah i i made
like a second channel video like trying
to process it but like even then it was
just kind of like
yeah the entire time i'm just like it's
so hard to describe without you being
there to experience it because there was
one part i think one of the most
powerful parts in this like oh i think
it was like what two and a half hour gig
or something it was it was quite a long
like three hours almost three hour gear
what made you want to make a video about
it if you couldn't really explain it
because i don't know so like one of i
think the most amazing parts about
cigars music is that like it they
utilize silence silence to their
advantage
to like create this like tension in
their music so there was one part in the
in the concert where
in the middle of the song
they just stopped playing
and they were just standing there in
silence for about 30 to 40 seconds
but the thing is it's like a little fart
in the background no no dude i've never
heard that was probably what like it was
full capacity right and this place can
hold about eight thousand eight thousand
people big hole right in order and i've
never heard eight thousand people being
that silent in my life
there was not a single person talking or
making noise during this like 30 40
seconds of silence and it was the most
intense moment i feel like it was longer
than 30 40 40 seconds right because you
you had i think i feel like everyone had
the same kind of experience where they
stopped the song and you're just like
okay must be moving on to the next one
yeah and then you know when someone
holds a silence for a bit too long it
starts to become uncomfortable so they
held it past the point of uncomfort that
you've you discovered that it became it
went from uncomfortable silence to
comfortable silence it was such a
[ __ ] surreal experience it was if if
i had to put into words it was the
loudest silence i'd ever heard in my
life yeah right i'm just like that's
that's the best way i can describe this
because it was one of those moments
where you just like kind of forget to
breathe and then once the music kicks in
you're like oh yeah that's right now i
know where i was sick and and and it's
so cool as well because they utilize
these like lights in such
like
cool ways so like during this silence
there's just this like kind of yellow
light that's just like pulsating
just silently
and it's just going on and on and on
they're not moving at all not a single
note and everyone's just sitting there
just like waiting
and it was the it was the weirdest
feeling it was so cool i've never seen
any band do that in a live setting and
i'm just like the balls
to be able to do that and everyone just
immediately know exactly what's
happening being like this wasn't like a
mistake or anything this was just part
of the show yeah so definitely 10 out of
10 would go again oh [ __ ] you i i hell
yeah 10 10 hour [ __ ] 10 out of 10.
yeah so easily and i've been to like a
lot of really [ __ ] cool concerts but
like just this one was like
it was more like watching a stage show
if anything it wasn't like going to go
see a band it was like if you it was
like kind of what you feel after you've
seen like a life-changing movie mm-hmm
what what's a life-changing movie for
you well i don't know like batman yeah
being like god
never look at batman the same ever again
but like you know you know there's those
movies that just kind of like on a
personal note that just like viscerally
hit you to the point where
after that
your your standard of movies just change
yeah yeah you know so if like for me for
example like the first i remember like
the first time i watched like pulp
fiction you know like before that i was
like oh you know movies are cool and
everything and then afterwards there's
just like there's one of those movies
where you just watch it and you're like
how do you go up from there you know and
i and everyone has you know a movie or
you know maybe some people haven't
discovered that movie but like i feel
for me
that cigarettes concert was that
but for concerts yeah okay so like i'm
afraid to go to my next concert because
i'm like because like it might be just
go to a really [ __ ] one yeah it might be
[ __ ] great it might be a band i've
always wanted to see but i know in the
back of my mind there's going to be that
one little voice that's like you know
it's not as good as the cigarettes
concert is it
you're gonna be chasing that high for
the rest of your life absolutely yeah
because i know you mean because i was
obviously out there at the concert as
well
i was there too i was there too guys
don't forget about me i was there
life-changing concept guys what can i
say my life was also changed guys
okay do you think okay do you think
there are films that you experience and
you might you might watch right and
there's a there's a big difference
between
films that are basically made for the
theater and films that can just be
watched anywhere because i i feel like i
didn't
because i i didn't really understand the
whole like cinematic experience it's
gonna be sound really cheesy but the the
first [ __ ] movie that made me feel
that was [ __ ] your name man just like
[ __ ] i i know guys i know your name
your name never you'd never watched a
movie before your name no no no no this
could be improved in the cinema
yes
what yes
i i had never seen a movie in theaters
that just made me go wow that was that
was the [ __ ] up that table
for me
because
for me that was akira
when i saw when i saw akira in cinemas
when they redid it for like i think it
was like the 20th anniversary of the
25th what was this
this was like four or five years ago
none of you had ever watched a movie
before that and thought damn this would
be so good in the movie no no what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] okay because i i kind of
but the thing is i kind of my excuse for
that was because my dad is a massive
film buff he put so much money into like
the home surround system
it's not going to be the same
i'm like this is good yeah yeah but but
like for me i've i've the cinema has
always been haha bigger screen louder
sounds cool
the way you view music is the way i view
films no because it's like your tv is
[ __ ] all the colors and all the [ __ ]
is wrong it's not what they they wanted
it to look like it it looks exactly the
way supposed have you have you tried
watching some movies on your tv at home
it looks like [ __ ]
uh most films i watch i feel
you know when one one i thought when
when i talked about silent green they
didn't know those people
know it's people when i talk when i talk
about like when i talk about cinematic
experience i don't mean cool you know
this would this experience would be
improved by watching in theaters because
ninety percent of the time okay yeah
okay it wouldn't be you're implying okay
no like are you saying like your name
was the first one that made you think i
i have to watch this in the cinema where
i'm like this can only be enjoyed in the
cinema like to to
me no
to me to me it's something like
something like your name and i feel like
what's the newest mum of her soda feel
whether it's like it's like having a
meal at a an ubereats or a restaurant
it's like it's it's like always meant to
be at the restaurant and yeah you can
have it there no not every film not
everything i think i feel like 90 80
percent of films are just way better in
the cinema no do i watch weathering with
you in cinema when it came out and then
i watched it again at home kind of the
same
experience
i can't say but like you know like a
quentin tarantino film like every one of
those should be watched in the cinema
well i never watched paul fiction in the
cinema yeah i never know one of my
favorites
like anyone that comes out now i'll try
my best to watch them in the cinema
right like i i feel like most films are
just so much better in the cinema
because it's like it's like the way that
they they every single aspect of the the
creation process was with that screen
and that that you know that size and the
the colors and everything was all that
right that exact specification